what if you are a person who is hiding
jews in nazi germany and a nazi guard
knocks in your door and asks you are you
hiding jews
how might you respond
kant would say you may not tell a lie to
the nazi guard
you might tell a lie because you think
the consequences are good if you tell
the truth then the nazi guard will seize
those jews and send them to a
concentration camp and possibly to their
death but khan says morality has nothing
to do with calculating good or bad
consequences morality is following a
universal duty
what kant tells us is that morality has
nothing to do
with emotions or inclinations
why not
because our emotions and inclinations
are in the world of experience and the
world of experience is a world of matter
in motion determined by necessity
similarly
kahn thinks that morality has nothing to
do with happiness that means also that
morality has nothing to do with goods or
the good
why because goods and the good attract
our will
we're back in the world of appearances
and of that deterministic matter and
motion
finally morality has nothing to do with
consequences
so you might be wondering right now if
morality has nothing to do with emotion
with passion with inclination with
perceptions of happiness or the good or
consequences what in the world can
morality be about
duty alone
has to be the justification
for morality what happens when someone
sacrifices something that they want for
the sake of duty
how about when someone gives up their
life
risking themselves to save someone
then we say that action merits esteem
that is a moral action
so kant wants to understand duty
most clearly
when it's against an inclination
duty
for the sake of what
khan says duty for the sake of
a moral law in itself
comes the question
where do we get
that moral law
how do we find it
because it can't be a good or happiness
or a law of nature how do we know what
our duties are
kant
gives us a way to decide this
he calls it the categorical
imperative
categorical meaning there are no
exceptions to it
an imperative meaning it makes a command
on us
the easiest way to see this
is through
an example he gives
he uses the example of someone who is in
a difficult situation
they're in need
they need money for example
and the only way they can get the money
is to promise to pay it back
but they know
that they can't ever pay back the money
the question is
can you make a false promise
when you need to
here's how kant answers the question
he says
universalize
that into what would be a law of nature
and see if you can accept it
in the particular instance that kant
gives i'm faced with a question may i
make a false promise
underneath
convert that to a maxim
a rule what's the rule under which i am
proposing to do this particular action
the maxim would be something like this
when someone is in need he may make a
false promise
that's the universal maxim that i am
proposing to follow in this particular
act
finally kant says
pretend that that maxim was a law of
nature
so that everyone who is in need
would have the right to make a false
promise make it a law of nature in your
imagination
could you will a world in which everyone
could make a false promise when they
were in need
kant says
clearly not
why
because if everyone
could make false promises in need then
all trust would break down
and society and social cooperation would
be impossible
so kant thinks that we must somehow give
the moral law to ourselves
in order to be free
kant thinks we must be self legislators
we we can't derive that law from
anywhere else we have to give it to
ourselves
in our practical reason
this is why kant says that moral action
must be autonomous it must be free the
word autonomy is rooted in a contraction
of auto nomos
self-law we have to give ourselves our
own law
now khan's understanding of this is very
demanding in exacting as you might have
noticed if i'm gonna be moral
all of my actions must be such that the
maxim that determines my action i could
will as a universal law
independent of all consequences
independent of all inclinations
independent of my own good independent
of all of my concern for happiness
that's very demanding
today when we think about autonomy we
tend to think of it as my right to do
whatever i want so long as it does not
harm anyone else
we take it to mean my right to create
myself to determine my own ends but that
is very different than what kant meant
by autonomy
you